[Music]
yeah scale Westown another exciting
Wednesday so today I'm gonna bring you
1/3 of DCs Holy Trinity I'm gonna bring
you the powerhouse bringing you Superman
when you think of Superman you think of
Christopher Reeves and I think he was
the most iconic Superman that there was
I mean we had a whole bunch of
Superman's back in the 70s in the 50s I
believe probably it was something of the
forties um I was born then so I wouldn't
know but you know Superman always he
always will have a place in my heart for
the TV shows for the movies for showing
that you know it was out of place but he
made it here in the human race so I
really appreciate all the information
the books the stories that we got from
Superman one of the most heartfelt
stories were was the death of Superman
when I read that book blew me away but
we're here to talk about sideshows
Superman now they've reimagined they're
Superman is it take on the new 52 if
you're up in the books DC has reset the
universe again and it's called the new
52 so they erased a lot of people
history they changed a lot of things
but still iconic heroes that we know you
know to keep it fresh to keep the young
kids and a new generation reading these
iconic heroes so this Superman suit if
you may notice it has no red underwear
has a little red belt and I kind of dig
it I think the the take on a suit is
still iconic but is a little bit
up-to-date you understand it's a nice
change of pace but here where is the
face that you get from size show where
his face is strong he shows strength his
build is muscular without being over
muscular like a bodybuilder you know
Superman has a very defined body but not
overly strong like that new Superman
don't like the new Superman but um this
Superman is more iconic you can check
out the Cape the Cape that comes with
this Superman is fabric cape remember
what I told you guys about mixed-media
well this is a mixed-media cape and this
is the exclusive Superman wear comes
with a switch out head
well not his head but in his hand if you
look at the base
it's a brainiacs base Brainiac is one of
Superman's most treacherous villains and
he's a robot
kind of like Marvel zoltron pretty much
the same but he can make little more
brainiacs so he's fighting on the
Brainiac base you can see Superman has
destroyed that premia case and he's
holding in the exclusive sideshows piece
that comes with it because
sideshow when they send out exclusive
pieces you get maybe a switch out head
arms poseable stuff well today you have
a switch out hand and in that hand he's
holding brainiacs Hey
highly-detailed you will always hear
that from me because of something that's
not highly detailed there's nothing to
brag about
but that hey that switch out ahead is
super detailed and if you look at the
pictures up at the side you can tell
that they kept the green ooze from him
the head looks like it's been
decapitated it looks very well done if
you look at Superman boots the detail on
the statue is great I'm happy to bring
you one third of the Holy Trinity from
DC and remember the whole Holy Trinity
in DC is Superman Batman and Wonder
Woman not in that order could be Wonder
Woman Superman Batman or it could be
Batman Wonder Woman Superman
it doesn't matter whoever your
preference is but I look forward to
bringing you more of the Holy Trinity
then since I hide DC this has been
another exciting episode of Kos king of
the statues we're fresh off four packs
and we have tons of content to give you
guys so don't forget to like follow and
subscribe iron Lords podcast where every
week kos will be up you'll get combat
toke by the king this guy right here you
can also go to Lords of gaming dotnet
where we have tons of content from shows
that we go to to other podcasts that we
do and also if you listen to the last
word if you a looter shoot a nut you can
definitely get information on destiny to
division to anthem all these great games
possibly Borderlands 3 so stick around
watch them boxing this is just some
great music and see you next week when I
bring you something epic Kos take care
guys
[Music]